c'est pareil et c'est un garçon heureux
il est heureux oui oui dans son paradis
bien fermé de mur ce sont les femmes qui
règne sur ce complètement ses matriarcat
sicilien complet c'est à dire qui est
aggravée dans le cas de la famille de
fulco par le fait que sa mère est
divorcée fin du morceau éponyme sera
prononcé elle est séparée en fait ne vit
pas avec son mari lui nourrit pour les
femmes en ville c'est ça il est fait il
a tout pour plaire
et si l'enfant est entièrement élevés
par la mère puisque en sicile lance le
fils mâle appartient à la mère plus qu'à
tout autre beaucoup plus qu'au père et
par la grand-mère personnage omnipotent
qui le personnage de ninon c'est ça qui
est l'angélique qui et l'angélique du
départ et qui a perdu la foi c'est là
perdu la foi et justice il est mal a
perdu la foi le jour où en quelques
heures entre 9h et 12h sont six le
deuxième vice maire d'une fièvre maligne
qui emmène emporte le petit garçon en
quelques heures et l'horreur de cette
mer devant devant ce petit corps qui va
perdre la vie fait que jour au lendemain
elle devient complètement adapté chose
étonnante pour disons un aristocrate
français qui est tout à fait normal pour
un aristocrate sicilien et on ferme la
porte de la chambre
tout reste en place les pantoufles du
petit garçon son vélo son dernier petit
de voir les petits souvenirs qu'il a au
mur et c'est la vieille nourrice qui
montrent une fois par semaine une fois
par semaine elle seule à la clé et elle
fait le ménage et elle ressort ce qui
est fascinant dans ce livre est ce que
vous dites d'ailleurs un peu ça c'est un
goût frénétique de l'exactitude et à mon
avis ce qui donne un son intérêt au
lycée justement tous ces petits détails
qu'on donne sur la vie par exemple il ya
une page du tour absolument superbe sur
les baisers que l'on donne à la jeune
marié dumas partir ça alors c'est
absolument et c'est toujours vrai hein
je vois parfaitement vrai oui la la la
mariée qui part en voyage de noces et
sur lequel elle part pour le continent
puisse convient le continent en parlant
de l'italie ou en parlant de la sicile
si on est dans une plus petite île que
la sicile tout le reste du monde
sicilien est toujours le continent
alors la mariée la avec le mari est il
ya un ordre protocole c'est le
grand-père qui a le droit de l'embrasser
en premier puis la grand mère si un
arrière-grand-père évidemment c'est lui
qui commence et l'enfant raconte la
friture de baisers parce que petit il
entend des cetc baiser c'est déco et il
compare ça à l'huile trop chaude dans la
poêle et puis alors alors on finit par
les derniers et les petits nouveaux nés
qu'on lui tend à qui lèche est il d'être
est drôlement la mariée montent à bord
avec ce qui lui reste de visage couvert
de tous d'autant que les vieux
recommence encore absolument
et puis